we begin with the extreme heat expected
in parts of the west and much of the
central us for the next several days
daytime temperatures will soar into the
mid to upper 90s you see it here from
california to the plains and across the
central and lower mississippi valley
temperatures over 100 degrees very
likely in some places our chris
vancleave reports on how dangerous such
weather can be
we've got help coming okay and she needs
you to be calm
calls for help due to the scorching heat
have more than doubled in fort worth
soaring past 450 so far and there's no
relief in sight from the triple digit
texas heat what happened to you we met
rex denim in the back of an ambulance he
fell during a mile walk home do you
think the heat played into you getting
dizzy it's pretty hot out yeah
i'm 65 years old medstar paramedic
supervisor john hamilton says he's never
seen heat calls like this
how dangerous is this heat
this kind of heat can kill you it feels
like a sauna it is so hot
on the tarmac in houston record high
temperatures take a toll on the ground
crews you microwave potato whenever you
get it out it's basically
steaming high you can't really pick it
up and that's how your body is walking
around houston it's going to feel like
it's in the low 100s but for these guys
working down here on the tarmac it feels
a lot hotter take a look at this 126.
you're getting heat not only from above
but it's also reflecting above all this
concrete back onto you ray hernandez is
keeping watch as his team works some of
the 465 daily united airlines departures
what do you tell your guys at the start
of the day when you know it's going to
be a hundred plus degrees out here
our focus is to try to take care of one
another
taking care in heat that just won't quit
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleeve in houston
so many people work outdoors all the
time construction workers people on the
tarmac i mean this is this can be
dangerous we got to stay hydrated folks
you cannot drink enough water england's
having a heat wave as well this is
becoming much more common hydrate